ah
[Music]
before we get the podcast started i just
want to let you guys know that there is
a massive
jim shark sale happening on june
7th only do two of these a year it's
happening
at seven o'clock on june 7th if you
click on our link in the description
below
all of the information will be there
when you do click on our link
it will track that you are one of our
guys so that actually helps the podcast
appreciate all of you and i hope you
enjoy the podcast
what was your first memory of floyd
mayweather i was
seven and i was browsing my school's
library and i saw this really shiny book
the guinness book of world
records and the title for this
particular world record was the world's
highest paid athlete and i looked at the
picture and it was this young man by the
name of floyd mayweather and
vividly i remember thinking how much
money does this guy make you know
tens of millions of dollars back then
and i thought wow the floyd that i'm
gonna
be going in the ring with is not the
same floyd that you guys saw and no one
remember like i'm fighting a grand dad
like he looks old he's aged
and that's why i laugh when floyd's like
oh june 6 i'm gonna knock you out like
with all due respect mr mayweather what
the [__] do you know about knocking
people out it's been a decade and i and
i even said this on stage
the only thing i kept thinking was this
is the guy the greatest boxer of our
generation i was looking down i was like
this is the [__]
is it like underwhelming but like he's
got a serious [__] temper problem
it's almost like his kryptonite if you
can just get under his skin like which
i'm going
i'm gonna be a [__] [__] in the
ring dude and he's gonna get pissed off
and i'm gonna end up fighting an
emotional angry floyd mayweather because
he can't control himself like i'm gonna
say some [__] up [__] dude imagine i
got pretty good in this past year and a
half
imagine i didn't like the way that
defeat felt and i worked really hard to
sharpen my blades and become a really
really good boxer floyd is banking on
the hope that i suck
[Music]
[Applause]
you win just by even looking good here
you know if you
land a good shot on him that you can
play at the start of impulsive on the
intro
end of story you've won
i think he's gonna catch a really really
really hard shot to the body or to the
head
he's gonna go oh [__] because they're
gonna be coming all night he's not gonna
want to get caught by it
let's say you're in the final round
you've got one more round to do it oh
and just go oh yeah i'm going for it
yeah for real yeah
i'll go for it yeah
you ready to go bro i'm ready let's get
it are you [__] tired are you poor
guys
this is what a man who's you know ready
to take on the world looks like
apparently
yeah homeless and [__] homeless
uh welcome back to treasury podcast the
guest
today friend of the show at this point i
mean
what's this three or four times logan
paul
jordy it's always a pleasure to see you
man you have such good energy
i love your show i love your set i love
talking to you
i'm happy to be here man thanks for
having me on i want to say
just at the start of this like before
all of these espn guys were interviewing
you
i was the one who was asking okay i
cared about you before all these people
do
all right i know i know and i'll never
forget that
even even the uk love you now and i was
the first one
and they all hated me because i like you
so
i deserve credit for this uh i was here
first that's all i'm saying
um i i i know bro i i really do
appreciate that like
it means a lot to me you've always been
a real one you've always told me how it
is
on and off camera and that meant a lot
to me too you know uh
back in the day you you were willing to
have those tough conversations with me
off camera
which not a lot of people are and that
that means a lot to me man no i
appreciate you mate and
yeah i think i just want to keep it like
this for the whole podcast here today
because
uh from the outside looking in like i i
remember
having that first podcast with you
before the ksi fight
you look like a kid you know what i mean
you looked so young back then
when i watched it recently and i was
like [__] hell this skinny little kid
who
the whole world hated you in that moment
and and there you were going out in
front of 20
000 people in manchester screaming
hoping you were gonna get knocked out
and you know that took a lot of balls
and to see what you've
gone on to do and the transformation and
all the growth and now
mind-blowing [__] fighting me with that
i'm so
[__] proud of you mate i'm so proud
of you thank you bro
yeah it's been crazy um i think the
biggest thing that i can hope for
um for anyone who's been watching my
journey is that
it can inspire and motivate people uh i
think
one of the most powerful things about
someone like you or i or anyone in our
position where
you know you have people paying
attention to what what you do is the
ripple effect
um and and and that's honestly the
energy that i'm carrying into this fight
like this this
this fight is crazy let's be honest you
just said it like
for anyone to land a fight with floyd
mayweather is
is insane um for me
i can't it's incomprehensible i i i've
surrendered
to the journey that is life and um
mine has led here it was an opportunity
that came up i couldn't say no to it
because i love rising to challenges and
putting on a on a show
and uh i'm going in with the energy of
possibility like let's be honest bro
no one really thinks i'm gonna win this
fight except me and my team
you know um and i've been proven people
wrong my whole life and i'm going in
there with that uh
you know nothing is impossible attitude
and and should i pull this off man
i don't want anyone to tell me
anything's impossible ever again like
this is this is gonna be
you know the greatest upset in the
history of combat sports
and it's just exciting just before we
move on there's a lot of noise in the
background
uh oh yeah did you have a word with uh i
don't know if someone moving around or
something
oh yeah yeah yeah right right hey
about a podcast goddammit
shut the [__] up yep basically
can we move the pigeon outside yes oh my
god
this guy's got a [__] pigeon i've got
a bird i got a
dude you're weird i love it a weirdo
like i've had people have noise in the
background of a podcast like this before
but never because they
they're pigeon needed let out that's the
first no i i know bro well because he
gets excited when he hears me talking
he's like oh we're doing this oh right
yeah yeah i hear you
i didn't know that's what it was i
thought someone was break dancing or
something
it sounded weird um so what was your
first memory of floyd mayweather
dude i love this question because i had
to
ask myself and figure it out because you
know he's been around forever
yeah this guy's old as [__] basically
he's a grand property
like i was
seven and i was browsing my school's
library
and i saw this really shiny book big
book looked at it it said
the guinness book of world records i was
like oh that's cool
well i like the cover of it it's it's
intrigued me and world records surely
there's something spectacular in here so
i rented it you know
brought it home and it was thumbing
through the book that night
and about halfway through there's this
big spread
big spread and the title for this
particular world record was the world's
highest paid athlete
and i looked at the picture and it was
this young man by the name of floyd
mayweather
and vividly i remember thinking floyd
may
how much money does this guy make you
know tens of millions of dollars back
then and i thought
wow this floyd mayweather guy really did
this this boxer is the highest paid
athlete in the world
more than the football players more than
the soccer players the baseball players
this boxer is the highest paid athlete
in the world that's awesome and that was
my first memory of floyd mayweather
[__] well i'll tell you what mine was
actually uh
back in the day we had a a boxer in
in the uk called ricky hatton of course
and i was a huge ricky hutton fan he was
like my one of my first
favorite boxers and he was undefeated
and i had all my hopes and i
hated floyd i still do be honest on a
level
um and i was like we've got it
this has got to happen but the referee
kept separating them the entire fight
and
and really heavily favored floyd in that
you know because
ricky was an inside fighter and watching
my guy get knocked out by flight it it
broke my heart that was one of my
earlier memories of him but
that was a long time ago you know he he
ain't the same guy now floyd there is no
way he can be that
uh same guy now and i guess the question
is
um how much has the age we're going to
find out
um but the guy hasn't had a real a real
fight in five years and a lot can happen
in that time i'm jumping ahead a little
bit but a lot of people are writing you
off
but they're also i think
having a little too much confidence that
this is
prime floyd mayweather showing up here
people are imagining
that person and he cannot be that person
now whether or not
he's good enough to beat you as another
question but in the last fight i've seen
i mean i say a fight the exhibition he
did with that uh kid from japan
he did not look the same in that fight
even he didn't look anywhere near as
good as his old self so
i'm excited for you here i really i
really think that there's a lot that
could happen in this fight that will
shock people
the allure is this i think
people have this image of floyd
mayweather in their in their mind this
this ideal athlete the one that became
50-0
and like you said no matter how you cut
it
the floyd that i'm gonna be going in the
ring with is not the same floyd that you
guys saw and no one remember
and loved to watch it's it's just not
like i'm fighting a grand dad like he
looks old he's aged
bro father time takes his toll on
everyone granted
floyd is a is a specimen of a human like
i made this comment to someone yesterday
um
the rules of life don't really apply to
this guy
like he bro he'll train this is not a
joke he'll train six hours a day
and eat once and it's like burger king
or some [__]
and and that's it like you know the
rules of like health
don't apply to him he's just he's a
beast you know
um and i've heard that he's looking
pretty sharp inside his camps
inside his camp to this day like you
know i'm not relying on
on time uh solely
to have withered floyd to the point
where i'm going to destroy him but i
i i can imagine it's going to affect him
a little bit he's probably going to be
slower and
a little bit more frail yeah the the
reason i'm bringing it up is i think
part of the problem
for promoting this fight is that people
are saying
very black and white and um
and i don't mean that on a racial level
as much as floyd might want to make that
in that you know like this is a young
guy who is inexperienced versus a guy
who's got a lot of experience but
yeah i think that in selling the fight
that is something that has not
been explored it's logan is not good
enough he's yadda yadda
no one says anything about floyd floyd's
perfect and yeah for 44 i'm sure he's
amazing that i'm not taking that away
from him but i'm just saying
floyd isn't prime floyd and i think
that's something that people need to
remember too
it's you know it's tough bro like again
the whole the whole circumstance about
this thing is crazy it's the it's the
young buck who wants to test
his newfound ability against uh the old
sage
and um let's see if the let's see if the
master still got it
and it's the allure of like what if like
what it like oh logan you're gonna get
your ass kicked
but what if you knock out the greatest
boxer of all time because he
he's slipping in round three and and
doesn't think i know what i'm doing like
i've been
i've been uh painting this hypothetical
for people
imagine imagine i got pretty good in
this past year and a half
after my last fight with ksi imagine
imagine i didn't like the way that
defeat felt and i worked really hard
to sharpen my blades and become a really
really good boxer
sparring three to five times a week for
the past year and a half
and imagine i'm like a pretty decent
good cruiser
cruiserweight fighter like how would
floyd do
against a cruiserweight coming into his
prime
at this moment like that's not a fair
fight you wouldn't see that fight
floyd is banking on the hope that i suck
you know that's so real that is so real
like he's
he's hoping i i [__] suck yeah he
watched that ksi fight and he thought
easy money yeah dude i just i sucked in
that fight
something i watch i i watch it back i'm
like oh
this performance is is bad and like i
get it but like what happens if i go in
there and i'm like he goes oh
you know he's he's his reach is a little
longer than i
expected and he uses it well and wow he
he hits hard
um there's a lot of weight behind his
punches and
holy [__] his reflexes are fat he's he's
fast and
reactive like and and another thing is
like if if you
for me as a as a fan of you as well as a
friend of you
you win just by even looking good here
or even you know if you land a good shot
on him that you can play at the start of
impulsive on the intro
end of story you've won that is that's
it
that's all you need he needs to finish
you if he doesn't finish you
then that affects him you don't need to
really
do a great deal to win out of this in
the aftermath
so i know um on the business level
though
this is not classic floyd either
i i feel like the organization of this
fight at times was a bit shambolic
the changing of the dates uh i know you
were frustrated when i seen you talking
about it on your podcast
the moving around he's suing dubai
because it's supposed to have been there
you know i could tell
they were jerking you around uh what has
it been like dealing
with him on a like on a business level a
unpredictable roller coaster
imagine you've strapped in to a roller
coaster and you don't know what it looks
like
yeah you have no power you have no power
bro it's floyd mayweather like
like thank you sir for blessing me with
this opportunity
where are we going what's the ride look
like like up down left right i'm in
uh whenever wherever like i just had to
be ready for the past eight months
you know like the mo the moment that the
fight was confirmed
we we are in camp and it's a six week
camp like six weeks official notice
that's what he does that's what he did
the connor he did the same thing to
conor mcgregor
where he gave him the bare minimum time
to get ready for it
yep well i mean the old cliche if you
stay ready you don't got to get ready
which is what we did like
the moment this fight was on the table
man we went into we were into
like official training six days a week
and we've been doing that for the past
eight months
wow um and obviously
all right it's floyd mayweather and what
he's done the guy's greatness as much as
i dislike him he's he is greatness and i
appreciate that but
i feel like some of the lack of
excitement for this fight is
is on him as as well his star
has diminished significantly and a lot
of people
who are boxing heads don't really say
that i'm i'm
a mainstream boxing fan so i feel like i
understand
what the masses are entertained by and
if you look back pre-conor mcgregor
he fought berto and he did 400 000
pay-per-view buys now that is pathetic
for someone who has supposedly
missed our money wait what yeah he
fought berto before mcgregor and that is
and nobody cared because people knew
yeah that is bro bro you did 1.3
against ksi just to put that into
context for everyone watching
so oh my god this guy needed a dance
partner
desperately because after pacquiao
people
realized the the game the jig was up for
flight no one
you know 400k were hardcore boxing fans
fair player but
he needed connor connor brought the
promo conor brought everything
and then after connor he probably made
so much money he's like i'm a chill now
but he needs you like if you look on
youtube right now
all of the views people don't give a
[__] about flight his views are
terrible people care about you so
and and i think partly from what rumors
are and
if that be believed he offered khabib
this fight and khabib turned it down so
he really
desperately needed you um wow
how does that make you feel
it's humbling it makes sense though
you know floyd floyd has the name but
do people really really care no
it but i think he's realized
that when his name is paired with
another big name or the right name
obviously if you will
that's where the magic happens it's
almost like even when we have the right
guests on impulsive
we know which episodes are gonna we knew
tyson was gonna fly we knew six nine was
gonna fly like we know
when there's that perfect collaboration
because of how big both names are that's
when the amplification uh
happens but the problem for him
obviously was in the ring
after the pacquiao fight was such a
letdown people had just
been like we've see we know what you do
you defend fantastically you get the
decision
the jig was up for him and with connor
he found someone who could create that
interest again and i think he's hoping
that you're
the new connor but you're completely
different to connor
you know what i mean i'm so different
than kind of i told this to someone the
other day
i think i could beat conor in a boxing
match right now like conor
doesn't impress me he gets tired uh
great athlete great performer but like
i don't know man eventually we're gonna
get good enough at this sport where
those conversations are are really
happening and we're better than most of
these guys
um and that's why i laugh when floyd
when floyd's like oh
june 6 i'm gonna knock you out like with
all due respect mr mayweather
what the [__] do you know about knocking
people out it's been a decade
it's been a decade and you knock when
you since you knocked out victor ortiz
and that
whatever [__] that was yeah like
does that even count
yeah exactly uh i mean i didn't like
to be fair to connor i did enjoy the
whole brittle fists jokes that he used
to make about him in his
fantastic yeah i love i love connor i'm
just saying in a in a boxing match like
yeah i hear you you're massive bro i've
this is the thing people don't get how
big you are i've stood next to you i'm a
big dude like
i was shocked at how big you are so
that's going to be an interesting
thing just even seeing you in the ring
with flight but when you went face to
face with him at the press conference
uh what was it like just finally locking
eyes
yeah um i i kid you not and i and i even
said this on stage
the only thing i kept thinking was this
is the guy
like this is this is the larger than
life personality highest paid athlete
in the world the the greatest boxer of
our generation i was looking down i was
like this is the [__] this is it like
slightly is like underwhelming
i don't know not a letdown for me it was
exciting i was like oh [__] i'm really
gonna do this like i'm gonna do this
yeah i'm gonna do this dude it's like
i'm gonna beat this guy who everyone
says is so great like i'm just not
not intimidated not uh i don't know
impressed yeah i i feel like the age gap
really showed in that press conference
it felt awkward at times
you were so funny jake turned off his
when jake turned up he took off his head
man
well even before that though when you
were talking to each other like
he reminded me of floyd senior like you
you know he was completely out it was
embarrassing for him like i'm like
you got this young kid who understands
like modern day culture
and this guy who's really trying to stay
irrelevant and he's like
he could say what do you want to say he
can feel how he want to feel i'm like is
that the best
you've got oh mentioned in japan that's
original like it was
it was just awkward it really he wasn't
doing a good job
no man he's like he's like the uh the
dad who's trying to stay young
you know what i'm saying like like we we
get it that you're
your time has passed and he landed on a
on a nickname for me in one of his
recent press conferences that i think he
liked a lot
he called me logan fall okay and i think
he thought that that was his zinger that
was the zinger
yeah he got him on that one he goes he
goes yeah logan
logan fall and i was like did your did
your security guard tell you that one
like uh
it's yes when when you came
up with the domestic abuse like when he
said
he can he can feel how he want to feel
he can say what he want to say
like dude you've just been you've he's
just brought you up on domestic abuse
yeah that's not something you can feel
how you want to feel about like
and and then he's like the thing is you
need proof
and and it's like well your own son
testified against you and put you
in prison so i'm pretty sure that counts
uh as well as like
the multiple by the way multiple
partners like four or five or whatever
the [__] it is
who have accused him of the exact same
thing yeah over a decade
like well well bro you know what i
realized just in the
in the past week man's got a temper
problem
like a serious serious temper i realized
it with the hat like i didn't know
you would think like someone of his
caliber could like
handle their emotions and stay collected
but like he's got a
serious [__] temper problem it's
almost like his kryptonite to be honest
absolutely it is if if you can just get
under his skin like which i'm going
i'm going to be a [__] [__] dude
like just an absolute [__] like
yeah absurd yeah and he's gonna get
pissed off and i'm gonna end up fighting
an emotional angry floyd mayweather
because he can't control himself like
i'm gonna say some [__] up [__] dude
yeah yeah yeah absolutely uh you know
the domestic viewers thing
obviously yeah he's a scumbag but
does that you know you've gone from
you've gone from fighting ksi who
obviously there was a rivalry there but
underlying respect
how differently does that make you
approach this is that in your mind at
all are you just trying to stay like
boxing
no it got oh so i was gonna keep it like
you know professional slash respectful
like boxing centric
um until he started threatening my
brother's life yeah
over the hat thing like that's when i
was like okay this [__] this is not a
[__] game anymore like
yeah i already know what he's gonna try
to do bro he's he's gonna you've seen
scarface when they kill the brother in
front of
i think it's scarface they torture they
torture the brother in front of
yeah yeah tony montana yeah
so he's gonna it's like like that type
of [__] like he's gonna try to make an
example out of me
for my little brother to see and like
hey [__] that b [__] you for threatening
my family
and also see like um would jake had that
uh
that alligator or that uh yeah the
allegation come against him
um the sexual assault allegation
without without knowing any of the facts
just jump to a conclusion and floyd
posted it on his instagram like went out
of his way
to post on his instagram to continue
badgering and badmouthing my brother's
name for a situation
that did not occur like with no with no
factual evidence and so
he's he's got this vendetta against jake
and
uh by default of uh now
that affects me and like it's shit's
just really personal
you know um floyd is a very
insecure person like why else would
someone
buy all the pointless [__] he buys
constantly
it's it's all a big show and on the
instagram thing it was nice of him to
take a break from posting strippers for
a change i i do credit him on that i
mean
what kind of man just you're an athlete
like
no wonder he's never had a brand deal
from uh like
nike any none of them have ever touched
him the guy's a [__] like
people credit him for his business sense
all right everyone wanted to see him
lose so he made a lot of money but
the guy literally pulls strippers seven
days a week on his [__] instagram
he's he he should be so much better at
business
he he he sinks a lot of money into into
[__] like uh
he i think he put money into these
skyscrapers that tank like
bro did you see him explaining that to
these guys sucking him up on stage and
he's like
so so i took a figures and i gave them
eight figures
and like and these guys were eating it
up and i'm like can we can no one see
through this guy's a [__] like he he's
a
he's a rich [__] but like greatness in
the ring
but a complete tool outside of the ring
um bro this this podcast is gonna be
called the roast of
floyd mayweather i don't realize you
didn't like him either
he's not pretty hot now [__] this guy
and conor mcgregor
do you know but this is the thing is i
do respect him in the ring and i
appreciate the talent but
outside of the ring i can also think
he's a piece of [__]
well i mean he is a piece of [__]
outside of the ring dude i don't think
like like no one
that's i don't think that's up for
debate like yeah i don't get why boxing
fans
kind of root for him in that way like i
think i don't get
because see i check this out humans have
this
weird thing where if one person
is so good at their art or their craft
they can almost kind of look the other
way in situations where they shouldn't
yeah like like michael jackson like
bingo
bingo like the denial of some people
and this is the thing is you're getting
a lot of [__] right now for
taking this fight and and as a as a
as fan of boxing i'm like hold on okay
this man's 50-0 and he's picking a fight
with a guy who lost his last fight
against another youtuber
and you're angry at the youtuber for
accepting the fight
shouldn't you be angry at the great one
who's asked who's actually doing
like surely if you're a boxing fan
you're looking at this site
canelo alvarez rematch triple g
any of those guys he's the one picking
fights with entertainers
be mad at the so-called goal yeah i
don't think i mean i don't think he
cares bro i mean you know he doesn't
he doesn't give a [__] right like
neither do i like i like
i'm so used to people saying x y and z
like not none of this [__] affects me
anymore so
like be mad at whoever you know
we'll be all right yeah well one of the
things he mentioned in that press
conference when you had a joke about him
uh the reading joke he made it a racial
thing which was bizarre uh i seen the
look on your face there
that was weird that was weird and i it
made me extremely uncomfortable
because i said something about you are
you reading off a teleprompter like
you can't even read and then what did he
say he just went off on a sort of
tangent about
the struggle of black people which you
know um okay
obviously we're all accepting of that
but this this is totally
he's trying to paint you out as if
that's what you were getting at which is
nonsense you know he's doing everything
he can to sort of
make you out to be the bad guy here yeah
i thought that was a bit of a reach
um and it's tough because it's it's
tough because i'm standing there on
stage like
um not not not ignoring or claiming i
even know
like a hint of the struggles of you know
african-americans or what they go
through black people
in general um but also like do i do i do
i push back on this note and be like hey
like i said i was like yo i'm on your
team what are we doing
i think the look on your face was
perfect it was like what the [__] is
this idiot talking about
like what are you what are you saying
bro why you gotta make
but like it's always about race and it's
like
but no it isn't all like nothing so in
my
that was my knee jerk reaction i'm like
no like this like this
doesn't seem so much about race but like
maybe for him it is like i don't know i
tried to be like somewhat receptive of
it because like
i'm sensitive to those conversations but
it that one threw me off man and
like i didn't i didn't think it was
incredibly appropriate like they
jake and jake had faced a little of this
after he knocked out nate robinson like
someone asked him
um yeah on tv they're like yo was it
racist that you knocked out near
robertson jake's like what the [__]
you're just like that was under like a
proper tv show as well i'm like
dude legit yeah and i'm like yo what no
it doesn't make any i i would have
flipped it so speaking of jake then so
he sort of
he that press conference was wasn't
going so good in terms of an
entertainment standpoint being brutally
honest like
floyd was was flagging massively and and
jake let a fire under it and
and what is it like looking at that
whole situation now when
i mean it was just mendel it's crazy i
was terrified for jake
like dude floyd's bodyguards and boys
could have
[__] him up like could have killed
them like literally and i
you don't realize until after the fact
that all they wanted was
the hat um but like i'm not
i'm not kidding jordy i was like i was i
was half expecting like to hear the the
pop pop pop
like gun like gun straight up over some
stupid [__]
um and and i'm all i'm gonna be honest
with you i'm always worried about that
with jake like i i swear to god dude i
never know what the kid's gonna do
what's worse he doesn't even know what
he's gonna do so
his impulsive decisions lead to
consequence unforeseen consequences that
by default i'm involved in and affect my
life
um he's the problem child what are you
going to do
i think look in reality if floyd had
just like
laughed at him and went dude you're
running away with my heart you're an
idiot
floyd looks like the the smart one and
jake looks like the idiot but floyd
is so childish that i feel like
jake is very good at like being that
childish provoker and like prodding
someone
and that is the the perfect antidote to
floyd because floyd is usually the
biggest child in the room
um and the fact that he like flipped and
i guess it was because of that terrible
hair job that he's had done
um that was really you know it's not a
good hair job to be honest with you
i hope they've got that fixed in time
for the fight because there's going to
be a lot of cameras there
um but what was show like showtime i'm
putting this fight on yeah
sure is it a showtime isn't it i'm like
yeah where the [__] is showtime like you
know when i watched the mcgregor press
conferences with
floyd there was [__] bodyguards
everywhere neutral guys
it felt like floyd just had like all the
heavies and you two are just trying to
fight these guys on your own
but we had a we had a rent a security
guard
like like like it was like a friend it
was a friend of jake's main security
guard like
i don't even know if he does it like
he's just a guy i know a guy literally
he was a he was a dude
we we might as well have gone down the
street and went hey you want
you need a job oh my god
it was it was bad we we were
ill-equipped man
uh i don't think any of us realized that
uh
it was gonna get that serious you know
that it
it's become a little bit of a joke
though like the fact that this guy
doesn't want to walk down the street
without being surrounded by
you know eight eight foot men like
he he doesn't want to get caught i get
that and and you know you don't
i don't get but it's a bit overkill do
you know what i mean like one bodyguard
should be enough shirley or
a three max yeah i don't even think
muhammad ali had bodyguards
yeah did he well yeah but it's just
weird i
i i find the whole [__] like bizarre um
but i'm going back to the chat without
so
uh after the ksi fight um you know
you're looking back on it now
you clearly aren't happy with the way
you performed
what was your sort of biggest regret
about the night
it's a great question um
i mean obviously my my biggest regret
would be uh
tapping him when he went down like after
i got him with the uppercut
that that last final punch where he was
like kind of on the ground and i
i just tapped him in the back of the
head like
i wish i would have pulled that punch i
wish i wouldn't have done that because
then then
i i don't i think it's pretty safe to
say like he would have got a 10 count
he still would have been pretty wobbly
and i probably would have finished him
off right then and there
but then again woulda shoulda coulda i
don't [__] know i just i
i vividly remember tapping in the back
of head the two points coming off
the five minutes of recovery time and me
just sitting there like well
that was my window good job logan you
[__] blew it
[__] um but when i was watching the
fight i remember thinking
you know you weren't pulling the trigger
and uh
and that was a real issue because
you technically probably looked a bit
better than uh jj
but but he was he was the aggressor and
and you just seemed hesitant and
when i spoke to jake he said that when
you were fighting
jj there was a maybe a little fear in
there or a bit bit too
uh careful do you still do you feel the
same about that
no i i i don't give any [__] anymore
because i can't and and that learning
lesson was experiencing that fight
okay you're right i i i remember being
i don't know like hesitant like i wasn't
throwing mm-hmm what the [__] like how
are you going to win a boxing match if
you don't throw
um and now it's like that's
that's all i want to do you know
i got to let the bombs go if i want to
win and do the damage that i know i
could do
and we've been working on it for a year
and a half man it's that it's that
killer mentality that jake has
a bit more than me my thing is i'm i'm
also a bit more calculated i'm a bit
more strategic and i don't put myself in
situations where i'm gonna get [__]
knocked out or memed um and so it's that
it's that it's that balance of like
throwing
and not being too vulnerable while you
throw recklessly
yeah i spoke to a um a very good boxing
or who's a pro recently and he said like
he's like the problem with me is i'm a
bit too smart for boxing and i was like
what do you mean he's like
i'm a little too aware of all of the
consequences and possibilities so when
i'm in there
there's some guys you see them the
berserkers who clearly
a bit like jake i guess who will just go
in there and think [__] it tunnel vision
and then there's other guys who a bit
more like yourself perhaps who
think a bit too much and i guess you've
got to switch that voice off
you you have to because bro the
berserkers as you call it the brawlers
like
when we spar i catch those guys because
they're [__] they're brawling and you
lose because you're not but i'm in there
like
like boxing using my brain i'm watching
every [__] move you do bro like
that's right
my my number one asset is probably my my
eyes my vision like i can i
see the punches that in in my reaction
time is quick
um and you're very fast for a big guy
for sure yeah i'm a fast switch and so i
catch the brawlers when they're going
crazy with these punches like lean back
on the ropes
like uh uh throw a big overhand like i
just see it and you get caught
um and so i don't want to be that
i don't want to be the thing that i'm
fighting against especially when i'm
fighting a dude like floyd
who is the counter puncher
he is gonna catch you if you [__]
slip up if you overextend a little bit
or don't extend enough or your timing's
off like he's going to get you
you know and so i i i i got to be
strategic
how and when i'm throwing absolutely
yeah
looking looking back at that training
camp and everything
you know you were in amazing shape and
even in the ring against ksi
yet you were slipping some punches you
just weren't making them pay as you say
uh there was no receipt there but um
shannon briggs
was your coach the head coach for that
he
has now moved on what was the decision
to move him on
based on i don't know because i i
thought shannon was a good coach
like i really did um because because he
was a good
boxer like he understood what
it meant to be the athlete in the ring
as well as the discipline that it took
to teach your student
but i felt to be honest with you
like milton supreme who's my coach now
and coached me for the uh
the first fight against ksi i felt like
i hadn't quite
finished the course if you will like i
had like
i got halfway through his teachings
and then switch things up when i felt
like i hadn't
there was unfinished business with his
style like i wanted to
fully absorb and learn it before i moved
on
to whatever like he's my mr miyagi
and his style works really well for the
type of athlete that i am
and i didn't i didn't i didn't master it
like i want to master it
and i think i think it's gonna it's
gonna be a really a really really good
strategic
elusive fighter in the ring once we do
that i did say that shannon
uh called out jake i don't did you see
that there was a
bro you call that me yeah how did that
feel when
you know you've paid this guy you spend
time together
like there should be a level of of
respect and loyalty there surely
that bro i don't like what is loyalty
what is what is respect like i don't
any of these virtues have i've been so
jaded by l.a like i just
i i i'm i'm numb to everything bro i see
i see some [__] uh and i'm like okay
like that's does it surprise me no
i don't care so someone like life is
weird this guy stabbed you in the back a
bit really by doing that in my opinion
and you you're just so used to it
getting the cue join the club bro
i'm used to that [__] i feel sorry for
you though because
you know people don't understand the
position that when you get to a point
where
you are someone who people can gain from
that
that loyalty is based on them gaining
from you and the minute that stops it's
like
read all about it i'm ready to talk i'm
gonna while you know audition the dirt
immediately yeah i mean
you know i i got i got no complaints
p humans are humans um
some have a better moral compass than
others
and i i i try not to hold anyone to the
standard that i
uh hold myself to because i believe it's
slightly unrealistic
um but you know you'll you'll find the
good people in your life that
that uh uh are on the same wavelength as
you
and you you keep them close and you know
you'll be good so you're speaking about
that style that milt
milton style and i did watch the video
with
you battering those four brothers and
it's it's a very unorthodox style and
and when i was watching it i was like
okay
he's taking risks here it could come
across as a sloppy style in regards to
the classic boxing style
but the styles styles make fights
as you know styles make fights um and
the amount of people who watched that
video
and commented on it uh you fight with
your hands down
you are going to get beat by freud if
you do this
you because boxing like everyone thinks
there's one way to box
what the [__] yo where where were these
comments when roy jones was fighting
where are these comments from muhammad
ali was fighting and like
i understand these are some of the
greats but like as someone who
also wants to be some of the greats and
the projection is there like
there's not one way to do something
here's my thought process when
if i was to do some of the things that
you do in front of my boxing coach
he would go no that's not how a proper
boxer does it now you're talking about
this style that you're cultivating
with milton is it ignorance or is it
deliberate because i think some people
are looking at you going
he's dropping his hands he doesn't know
what he's doing but what you're saying
to me is no
milton's very aware of what you're doing
and this is something that you are
creating together
bro we fight with our hands down
like it's and guess what sometimes we
don't like sometimes
for the gronk brothers i didn't need to
put my hands up for floyd i'm probably
gonna need to put my hands up like
okay like i i know both and uh i'm
versatile
that's it's one of my strengths i'm
versatile and so like
and with floyd we'll see we'll see what
happens bro i might need to
stick my hands right up here go total up
in my shell whatever whatever or like
maybe i stay elusive we'll see how much
of flight have you been watching
a lot but it's tough because like
he he's got every every tool in the shed
dude
absolutely what i'm saying he's good
he's his arsenal uh and his knowledge
when it comes to boxing is unlimited so
you never really know what floyd you're
gonna get
he and he and he watches you dude he
watches you like a [__]
like a robot like a computer bro he's
gonna come out
he's gonna take a couple steps to his
left he's gonna take a couple steps to
his right see how i react watch my
footwork see if i'm crossing my feet
whatever the [__] i'm doing download it
and set up like
four different punches off of each one
like every movement i make
and probably in the first like two to
four rounds he's gonna keep it real
light
and just watch me scan me
and then and then set me up for [__]
and so yeah we watch floyd but you know
what at what point
is it pointless it's funny though i was
watching a podcast with uh michael
bisping the ufc fighter and
he said you know even towards the end of
his career if he
if he spoiled a guy who was like you
know just starting or
you know didn't necessarily have the
exact technique
that you expect he would sometimes get
caught
by guys who weren't as highly trained
because what he's used to is
the highly trained guy who does the
textbook [__]
and possibly by you not having that yet
could be an advantage because you might
come at some at him with something that
is completely
unorthodox when i fought the garage
brothers
i watched back the footage and i'm like
uh uh like okay like it was
it was kind of sloppy you know it it
didn't look great
in my and after the fight
i talked to milton my boxing coach and
he goes a bad fighter can make a good
fighter look bad
because we're not in there doing the
typical
slips and rolls and yeah kind of kind of
playing chess with our fists like i'm
i'm
it's a bit more street fight like dodge
a couple punches make a miss
and just [__] unload my hands on
these on the other rookies
um that was a bit of fun at the end of
the day it was for a youtube video it
wasn't like
exactly exactly you were like four guys
yeah i get it
so so yeah man like i'm like i don't
have the 10
15 20 years of experience that floyd has
and i'm not gonna
be as ortho like bro i'm [__]
unorthodox
um but my jew i'm fully
uh equipped to handle floyd's plan
that will change in round four or five
when he adjusts and
does what he needs to do to try to get
in or
break me down whatever like bro he's
he's gonna be malleable you know
um and i think i think he's gonna catch
i think he's gonna catch
a really really really hard shot to the
body
or to the head or it's good one's going
to whiff him and he's going to go oh
[__]
i i don't want to get i don't want to
get caught by that because they're going
to be coming all night
he's not going to want to get caught by
it and so
i bet he's gonna be a little more
careful than he thinks yeah i'd like to
see some uppercuts just putting that out
there
um with his size um
oh my god did you uh the mcgregor fight
is the one that i always found
interesting because obviously that's the
last real competitive fight he had
and what we've seen was a very well
executed game plan from floyd
and we also seen some great mistakes
from mcgregor that i think you can take
a lot from and learn what not to do a
little bit because
although mcgregor did win the first
three rounds he worked very hard
he used all of his energy and despite
despite him having
better punching power than floyd it it
made
no difference whatsoever because floyd
was in defense mode the entire time
and then when he was nice and fresh in
rounds four five and six he put the
level up and mcgregor
was just surviving um yeah i mean i mean
i mean that that surprised me because we
know mcgregor's gas tank sucks
like we knew that going into the fight
and conor knew that like
everyone knew that and so i'm i'm not
sure if
he his plan was to truly try to knock
floyd out
the first couple of rounds which is like
a hard [__] thing to do like bro if i
knock floyd out
it's gonna be it's gonna be cuz like
god bless me with some miraculous [__]
and i catch him with some
dumb [__] because he thinks i suck like
i
this here's what's gonna happen i'm
either gonna knock him out or it's gonna
go the distance
but like my conditioning is sick dude
like i'm ready to [__] go
i'm not gonna punch myself out like i'm
not gonna get tired like conor
um i'm not i'm not gonna get excited
because maybe i landed
one big punch like floyd's got a chin
bro and he knows what he's [__] doing
earlier on you were talking about his
ego and that being his
biggest weakness and and i agree with
you and i feel like
conor didn't really use that at all like
if if i'm going this is my opinion but
like if i was
in your situation i'd be thinking put
all the pressure on floyd
you know i'm in there with him i'm
saying come on then mr big boxer
come and knock me out you come to me i
wouldn't be
going at him expending all the energy
i'd be counter-punching the counter
punch
i wouldn't be going in there trying to
bully him early on any of that
and and i'd be saving my energy for
those later rounds going
i'm gonna turn this [__] up in rounds
five six seven eight
i'm i'm gonna be making sure i'm ready
you know what i mean and i think um
the more you clown him and and and [__]
with him
the better like the more he is not
thinking about boxing and the more he's
getting frustrated and
if the crowd are booing early on it's
probably going well for you like to be
honest with you
that's how i say it hey i i i'll go i'll
go hey
hey the boo you champ yeah yeah this is
all for you
you're the [__] best ever i'm just
this youtuber
yeah why haven't you knocked me out yet
bro i'd be i'd be doing this i'd be
looking at my wrist
checking the time going i'm still here
another round i'm still here
oh another minute gone by you still
haven't knocked me out i would be
clowning him and just putting as much
pressure on him to come to you as
possible because
that that for me if by you know if
as people are saying it's a miracle if
it happens i think
you've got to make him go first if you
are going to catch him and especially
with that reach
that might be your best shot 100 100
baby yeah any more ideas pitching my way
i love that
i'll be great i'll do it checking the
time oh that's still alive
wow i got to call you back mom i'm
working
honestly honestly like just take the
absolute piss and clown him because
what he doesn't want is for people to
not want to buy the next floyd
mayweather fight and there will be
another
and and and the that
that's the best advice i would give you
and i'm not i'm not a boxer and people
might say you're talking [__] brian but
it's just truly what i think would be
the best method and if i didn't tell you
i mean i know some people say oh well
you should have told me in private and
say i doubt floyd is going to worry
about what i'm saying but you know
i genuinely think it would be hilarious
no no no no no no
floyd is extremely worried about what
you say i swear to god
bro the pettiest dude i know bro he
cares yeah
he cares about yo he he unfollowed a
friend
that uh is here in puerto rico because
he saw
he had a picture with us up up on there
like he's on that level bro
like one of his boys is gonna watch this
video hey
hey jay who the [__] is watching this
video and he's gonna relay the
information to him like he's paddy bro
he
cares uh what are the rules and you know
uh
club size rounds all that uh can you
tell us that yeah
dude dude i i don't know how this is
possible but i don't know
i do not know i'm here i'm hearing i'm
here 10 ounce i'm here in 12 ounce
i'm here in eight rounds i'm here in
three minutes i'm here in two minutes
like i don't [__] know the [__]
yeah oh i hope it's not two minutes that
would be
i mean that would be good for you but
yeah i mean bro we're prepared for
anything you know what i'm saying
we did a legit proper camp like i'm
locked the [__]
uh we're doing we're doing hard sparring
rounds 10 12 rounds
three different guys like we're ready
what what level of guys and uh
like describe to me some of the sparring
partners because obviously you're going
in there against a smaller guy
very high level but obviously that's
hard to source all the time so
how what kind of group is it yeah it's
we got
we got a group of pros um some guys are
brawlers some guys are boxers
uh we try to get guys who can emulate
floyd or at least you know keep the pace
small guys uh big guys like but i
honestly every look we can we get and uh
yeah
pros like like solid solid boxers
you know we spot a couple times there's
a jean pascal who is on my on the
undercard actually oh wow
well that is high level yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's great work too like a tough guy you
know um he was already here in puerto
rico training
and so we just happened to be at the
same gym and
got a couple sessions here when when you
moved to puerto rico
in the middle of a training camp uh i
was like wow that is
yeah that is a drastic thing what what
was it that made you want to do that i
mean i know taxes are better over there
but is there anything else too many uh
too many hoes in l.a bro including
myself
including myself just a hub when i'm in
l.a just the worst bro
okay okay the worst i had too many
distractions
gotta get out gotta get out of there bro
no more homes
yeah when when are you uh when are you
move uh heading back to do the fight
then how long
will you be in town before the fight
night
uh i'll be i'll be in miami june 1st so
next tuesday
okay i want to move out with the the
fight right now and talk about some of
the other stuff going on in your life
uh one of the main things people have
been talking about lately is you and
mike and the friendship and
is mike on impulsive what what the hell
is going on there
do you mind sharing with me where you're
at right now with that
um i i don't mind sharing the problem is
i don't know where i'm at
with it like i see he was on the other
podcast with with keem in that wasn't it
and
he basically said something [__] up
that was incorrect about why you
said something well that was the issue
that was the
the the catalyst and then
what people don't know is like there was
like a number of things that you know
had have been building up before that
but like i love mike
um i get it more than other people would
because i literally work with my best
friend
all the time and there's always little
things that you you know
that you might do with each other or you
might not agree on or whatever so
i do get it like you can love someone
but also just need a bit of a
bit of space or whatever the issue is
that it happened
right as i enter training camp so there
wasn't like a there wasn't a
a proper setting or time
to like really iron it out because i
entered training camp and like literally
bro i'm like i don't want to [__]
deal with this [__] let's handle it
after this fight like
like almost everything in my life every
like
relationship every business thing like
um
let's handle after this fight i don't i
don't care nothing else matters like i
can't see past june 6 in my mind
like i'm usually really good at um
mapping out my life and
projecting uh and extrapolating
but i i can't see past year six because
nothing else [__] matters to me
so you think um after the fight you and
mike can
have a chat and sort it all out
yeah we're grown man we'll figure we'll
figure it out for sure because you guys
have made a hell of a podcast together
and i also like the new guy georgie
as well like i think it'd be a shame if
that dynamic wasn't there
no we'll figure it out we'll figure it
out man um he just went through the
breakup with lorna as well
uh recently what was it like you were
the guy who set them up
and it was a crazy relationship how do
you say that do you think that's
a good thing for them or
yeah that was one of the most toxic
relationships i've ever seen in my life
wow like like like you know you can't
even imagine
and they both know it they will talk
about it it's just i mean bro
every relationship can get toxic and
when you continue when you try to like
ignore the toxicity and like continue
like we all know what's gonna happen
it's gonna get worse and worse and worse
until someone explodes
yeah or both of you explode you know but
again bro i'm so removed i don't know
what's happening with that i don't care
like uh
the jake paul career that you've watched
blossom and he's been killing it
what is it like to be seeing him
knocking people out being the
talk of the whole entire industry i mean
the whole you guys have got the
entertainment world on strings right now
he's got every mma fighter calling him
out
how's that been it's so exciting to see
jake doing as well as he's doing like
honestly uh
for for for a long time he he he lived
in my shadow
you know or at least that was the public
narrative yeah he was the undercard to
your your main event literally
exactly exactly and as an older brother
i never
that never was like an achievement for
me i was like ah like [__] dude like i
want him to i want him to just like
break out and be the [__] the
superstar
and in the past like year and a half he
did like he really did like he's [__]
jake paul dude
um and his his name makes people feel
and his name makes people tune in and
watch and
as a proud older brother that's that's
all i can ask for so just like
stoked to see him uh thriving in in the
way that he is
it's funny because i do remember uh 50
cent years ago when he was friends with
floyd
their relationship ended their
friendship ended he did an interview and
he did say
floyd will lose one day because he
spends too much money
and he will have to keep fighting way
longer than he ever should he was like
floyd is the goal
but he should he would stop at a certain
age and be done with it he won't
he'll keep fighting and this is that
fight
yeah he literally said he'll pick one
guy who will completely underestimate
and think easy money
and that's where it'll all come un
unraveled
bro i have to find this interview
because like that's
that's my exact sentiment yeah the old
man still thinks he got it and he chose
the wrong guy who didn't look good in
his last fight but got really good in a
short amount of time
and is a [__] dog and he's gonna come
in there with nothing to lose like bro
i'm ready to [__] die in that ring
like i'm i'm
straight up i'm coming back with my
shield or i'm coming back on it like i
am
given my heart have you made peace with
that possibility now because obviously
that was part of the concern with the
ksi fighters what if
are you like i'd rather i'd rather get
knocked out and
really go for it than have those regrets
for the months afterwards that i had
last time
it's all circumstantial you know what
i'm saying like uh
i i don't know
i don't know it just it depends like
because i think the risk of if i would
have went for it last time
i think the risk of getting knocked out
would have been lower
if i go for it this time on some dumb
[__] like just like
swinging wildly
i think i could get caught like we've
seen we've seen we've seen floyd
beat that before the wild no i guess
what i mean is
let's say you're in the final round and
it's you know
you know at this point you've just got a
you've got one more round to do it
oh and just go oh yeah i'm going for it
yeah for real i can imagine yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i'm going for it yeah you're
[__] yeah but i'm going for it i love
it
um i guess i've got one last question
bro
if someone said to me describe one thing
you like about logan paul it's this like
constant quest for growing as a person
you're constantly trying to evolve
all the time um and i was just wondering
like
where are you at right now with this
this internal
search yeah so the the question
described is like
one of the trade the traits i describe
myself as i'm a conqueror
like uh i i i can't get enough and so i
continue to do
um where am i at with with the quest is
like
this is probably one of the few times in
my life that i will be
really really really present
like i mentioned earlier i i'm always
thinking about
my past how i can learn from it
what what i can take and move on
and and use in the future i'm always
thinking about what i'm doing right now
i was thinking about my future like
and and how the three merge together and
what's best going to suit my life and my
ideals and pursuits
but with this floyd thing and to answer
the question where i'm at right now he's
like i'm right here baby
i'm i'm [__] i'm i'm locked into this
moment
i'm i'm thinking about june 6 and what i
need to do and like
to be honest i i don't i don't know is
the answer
i don't know i'm [__] right here i'm
right here i'm living
i'm courageously present and uh
june 6 is the one date on my mind
love it mate love it i'm absolutely
rooting for you
and needless to say if one of my mates
is the guy
to beat floyd mayweather i'll be stood
on that [__] table just like you were
in the last podcast we did
screaming he [__] did it i'm betting
on you
i'm putting money on you end of story
amazing absolutely
make you rich i love you um
obviously the day is set it's a sunday
night actually that's the difference
about
this is usually saturday night but this
is a sunday night isn't it
yeah which i actually was frustrated
with because like how are uk fans going
to watch it
because y'all got work and stuff to do
yeah we'll be fine
we'll be fine i'm staying up i'm staying
up
oh man that's gonna be crazy but yeah uh
it'll be on p
it's on paper view over here on uh sky
sports box office if anyone wants to
tune in
and uh yeah thanks again mate logan paul
from churchill podcast
legend thank you thank you jordy i love
you bro cheers bro say man
you